for it was it was just it was like a
sister who's lon order look if you a big
star know that but no no I want to
tell when I first give you guys a toast
oh because I think you guys are great
and you're like the last great couple
and so I just one day there's a little
toast Ted tweaks to that just great yeah
really cute cool I mean I'm so busy that
I can't it's weird because I'm like yeah
guys night
just make a story
yeah the Bruckheimer pilot on Monday the
breakdowns you saw it right
it with its part it's like late 20s
early 30s Irish guy strong but
vulnerable works out i mean it's it's
perfect you got to get me in there
please
I wanted
I came here basically because you you
know you mean a lot to me your good
friend of mine and I think I
um I'm leaving Los Angeles
what why not why you're going really
well well I was acting yeah but I
nothing
basically this film that was twisted you
know do things for me to do
will be the last time I'll ever see you
or I mean no no
okay you know I know how much you rely
on me
so it makes it even tougher you know
happen to come here and tell you that
I'm leaving this town of that you know
it's just an added toughness you know I
just have a few more people I need to
talk to and then
then I'm packing up packing up again
you know
definitely he definitely was not
supposed to be like this maybe Godsey
what you gotta do it's all yeah I guess
yep
I'm disappointed you're gonna be leaving
but
wellington doing what's best for you so
in the end I do want what's best for you
and if it's that's best for you and
sleep la them cattle be valet I'm sure
you'll find something makes you happy
now
oops no he doesn't get too fat yeah
someone's gonna walk her all by someone
but
okay babyliss they got a little grown-up
time all right so Cheers so so what's
going on yeah look good you look the
same yes is good thank you I'd like to
think after I had a baby I looked the
same how's class are you in class I
haven't been in it since man was boring
you know it was two weeks i think those
two weeks before she was born i did my
last class so okay so you're not in
class so how's that I mean I was acting
in general auditioning may gence no no I
never did have an agent and to be
perfectly honest I think I think I might
be done you mean I don't was class uh no
I think I'm done with acting you know I
I think I'm ready to let it go I know I
know it's very like done with the
pursuit of acting yeah believe me I love
the camera someone walked up to me with
a camera and said can i film you can I
put you in my movie can you be on my TV
show I'm sure I would probably do it I'm
not stupid but you know I'm not gonna
pursue it anymore it's just it's not
it's not my passion so much anymore that
little baby has become my passion so I
did
that's what felt right
go
but you know all right enough about me
what do you uh what's going on with you
honey just out there hustling yeah yeah
how's the hustle it's you know it's a
it's a hustle talked really i mean do
you really you really just came by to
see me and how I'm doing how baby is and
there's nothing else I'm fine just being
with a friend that's it's really all I
wanted to do is just you know and I
value you as a friend and I just wanted
to you know how I'll tell you maybe when
it's time but other than that I'm happy
just being here okay you don't have to
say about babies you don't have to pay a
thing no no worries you do know that I'm
gonna worry about you now though is he
going so don't go next week hey listen
how did you guys how did you guys meet
you never told me kind of a crazy day
you how do we meeting with him I was
working at a flower shop
she made credible Ranger for my
grandmother for him my you know five
minutes it was unbelievable and she must
have thought i had the biggest family in
the world i kept coming up with
different relatives to buy flowers
that's a good story
so the boy it's been fun yeah hmm all
right well if you need me let's see got
a phone call here okay that's probably
mom or something all right all right
thats hanging right it's good to see
thank you you too whenever you're
wrestling with I hope you figure it out
goodness okay bye sweetie
you